mitel bonjour et merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation ce matin sur rtl france
alors le convoi de la liberté qu'on
veuille france réclame entre autres la
fin de l'obligation vaccinale et
l'abrogation de la loi c'est tu as été
global certains estiment en avoir marre
d'être ridiculisé par le gouvernement
est ce que vous partagez cet avis
bonjour
oui je le partage et je partage d'autant
plus que ça fait maintenant quasiment 10
mois que avec beaucoup de camarades nous
sommes dans la rue chaque samedi et
force est de constater que ces
mobilisations parfois extrêmement
massive ont été rendues invisibles
par le pouvoir politique et par une
partie la classe médiatique rt faisant
exception mais sur des manifestations de
plusieurs dizaines voire centaines de
milliers de personnes où il n'y avait
aucune couverture nous n'existions pas
voilà comme au temps des soviétiques ont
effacé les opposants du récit du récit
officiel donc on a tenté d'alerter
d'agir par tous les moyens démocratiques
possibles en étant complètement balayées
d'un revers de la main et aujourd'hui le
combat les libertés apparaît comme la
solution pour enfin être entendu et
apparemment ça fonctionne puisque tout
le monde en parle alors tout le monde en
parlait tout le monde s'intéresse à ce
mouvement pour comprendre pourquoi qui
est présent également dansé dansé convoi
alors on parle de gilet jaune d'anti
passe dans thiva que ça il y a également
beaucoup de français qui dénonce tout
simplement le coût de la vie un
mouvement très hétéroclite est ce que
c'est important cette lutte cette
convergence des luttes
alors les raisons de
se révolter contre le gouvernement ne
manque pas c'est certain je crois quand
même qu'il ya une revendication qui est
au coeur de ce mouvement qui est la
revendication contre le pass vaccinale
est donc cette obligation vaccinale
déguisés et donc toutes les conséquences
en termes de ségrégation d'exclusion de
l'emploi d'un possibilité d'aller rendre
visite à des proches à l'hôpital ou en
ehpad il me semble que c'est vraiment le
coeur de la revendication des
manifestants qui ont pris inspiration
sur ce qui s'est passé au canada qui
porte d'ailleurs ses fruits ou le
reportage nous le montrer puisque
certaines certains mandats sont en train
d'être d'être levée donc si ajoute sans
doute indifférente différentes
revendications mais le coeur du sujet
c'est maître chien aux pages maximum
alors vous parliez justement de ces
manifestations dont on est maintenant
coutumier pratiquement chaque samedi
contre le pass vaccinale et les
restrictions sanitaires
il ya pourtant des moyens démocratiques
pour se faire entendre on est à la
veille d'un très grand rendez vous
électoral
alors nous sommes au rendez vous
électoral l'élection présidentielle aura
lieu dans 57 jours ce qui à l'échelle du
temps démocratique peut paraître
relativement faible mais lorsqu'il
s'agit de reprendre un travail de
demander le droit d'avoir un salaire
quand on a été suspendue comme soignants
d'aller visiter un proche mourant à
l'hôpital où on eepad ses 57 jours sont
une éternité et donc la proche de
l'élection présidentielle ne doit
certainement pas faire faiblir ce
mouvement auquel
auquel nous appelons tous les toutous
les français et qui permettra il faut
l'espérer aussi de faire pression sur
les candidats à l'élection
présidentielle
voyez quelques les quelques semaines de
ça j'avais lancé avec philippe muray
l'économie philippe morel un appel à
l'union sacrée on s'était tourné vers
les candidats à l'élection
présidentielle
certains avaient répondu mais force est
de constater que ça ne les préoccupe pas
davantage que cela est bien là ils n'ont
plus d'autre choix que de s'en
préoccuper dernière question le convoi
est de passage on va dire par paris
puisque les manifestants espèrent
arriver jusqu'à la belgique
d'ici lundi pourquoi c'est important
de se retrouver d'avoir comme
destination finale bruxelles
bruxelles parce que vous l'avez compris
c'est bien là le véritable le décisions
politiques en europe et emmanuel macron
est un exécutant en réalité 2 de ce
pouvoir
bruxellois je voudrais juste terminée en
soulignant la force des images que vous
avez montré des gens portés par une
révolte et une révolte de scène mais
aussi par une espérance qui met en place
en ce moment dès les débuts des
mécaniques que d'entrer dans ma bulle
ces groupes de prière on voit cet état
d'esprit extrêmement positif et je crois
que c'est la raison pour laquelle ce
mouvement l'emportera parce qu'il
propose quelque chose de positif il
propose quelque chose qui aide à
retisser du lien ce lien ac a été
tellement d'effet détruit mécaniquement
depuis depuis désormais donc je souhaite
à tous mes amis dans la rue aujourd'hui
et j'en serai énormément de énormément
de courage merci beaucoup rémi tales
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes co fondateur du
collectif peuple libre